bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo aux compagnies
cette semaine de delphine gérard bonjour
d'hollywood
alors dans l'actualité politique et
parlementaire de la semaine il ya
d'abord la cacophonie autour de l'accord
entre le parti socialiste et les verts
pour 2012
des verts qui reproche au ps d'avoir
occulté le texte final d'un paragraphe
sur la filière mox et de l'autre côté
des socialistes mécontents de
circonscription laissée aux écologistes
un communiqué commun parle finalement de
peu retrouvé à suivre la semaine a aussi
été marquée par la traque aux milliards
manquants pour financer le budget 2012
le gouvernement présente son nouveau
plan de rigueur qui prévoit 7 milliards
d'économies supplémentaires
nicolas sarkozy de son côté veut faire
payer ceux qui pratiquent la fraude
sociale
enfin les sénateurs socialistes poursuit
patiemment leur détricotage des textes
du gouvernement en début de semaine il
aurait écrit le projet de budget sur la
sécurité sociale avant de s'attaquer au
budget entre les deux ils ont aussi voté
une proposition de loi qui supprime le
conseiller territorial mesure phare du
quinquennat sarkozy
un texte qui a fort peu de chances
cependant d'arriver à l'assemblée est
avec nous aujourd'hui pour commenter
l'actualité de cette semaine alain
richard sénateur socialiste du val
d'oise bonjour alors vous avez été
député puis sénateur avant d'être appelé
en 1997 par lionel jospin pour être
ministre de la défense parce que vous
allez occuper jusqu'en 2002 aujourd'hui
vous retrouvez donc le sénat dans les
meilleures conditions possible puisqu'il
a basculé à gauche en septembre
en un mot est ce que le scénar depuis
sept ans est à la hauteur
les attentes suscitées par un tel
bouleversement politique je suis dedans
donc je peux pas parler pour ceux qui
ont des attentes et d'ailleurs ils sont
sans doute très variés démocratiquement
c'est en effet un
un moment singulier vue de mon point de
vue privilégié de vie parlementaire il
vient à l'esprit qu'au fond en tout cas
dans cette assemblée si nous allons
vivre ici à fin février une brève
séquence de régime parlementaire puisque
on va avoir un gouvernement qui est
appuyé par une majorité politique qui
aura à débattre autant que possible de
façon républicaine et est positive de
part et d'autre avec une assemblée
parlementaire qui a elle-même sa
diversité nous qui ne partagent pas tous
ses choix
avec ce bémol important quand même que
l'assemblée vous le savez est à droite
la majorité et qu'elle a le dernier mot
c'est un peu frustrant non oui mais le
dernier mot peut avoir différentes
sonorités et donc il me semble si vous
me demandez si le sénat sera à la
hauteur
or évidemment pas la poutre et quid ans
de porter un jugement sur toute une
collectivité mais en tout cas de mon
point de vue et y en a qui est un peu un
peu le travail politique au sein du
groupe socialiste
je pense que notre mission est de faire
vivre le parlement au sens propre du
terme c'est à dire un lieu de débats des
changes de confrontation d'opinions et
de proposition et donc pour ce qui est
de la nouvelle majorité à laquelle j'ai
une certaine fierté d'appartenir
quand même un épisode nom banal de
l'histoire parlementaire
notre défi et on s'y applique un peu
tous les jours c'est 2 lors de chaque
débat soit de texte à l'initiative du
gouvernement qui sont dans les navettes
soit de nos propres propositions
d'illustrer une alternative d'autres
choix pas toujours à 180° d'ailleurs je
vous en parlerai sur tel ou tel texte
mais de montrer que qu'il n'y a pas d'un
côté un gouvernement et une majorité de
l'assemblée qui serait omniscient qui
aurait réponse à tout et qui
présenteraient sur tout sujet la seule
solution possible
et de l'autre côté une opposition qui
serait impuissante au ignorante
finalement savage selanne est utile que
lorsqu'il est dans l'opposition vous
partager son ami c'est absurde bien sûr
le sénat il est utile chaque fois qu'ils
apportent un peu de d'efforts de clarté
de rigueur et de cohérence dans la
législation
moi je suis par mes choix et par mais
mon expérience quelqu'un qui aime faire
du travail de gist natif et faire des
lois qui ressemble à quelque chose
d'assez sa mission me semble-t-il
et il ya dans cette assemblée beaucoup
de gens qui sont attentifs à bien
l'exercer et puis d'autre part nous
sommes tous un peu les personnages
politiques qui incarne ont des idées des
préférences des attentes d'un public
démocratique et donc on essaye de les
exprimer de façon pas trop absurde
tu vas encore de cette émission que le
groupe soit votre groupe socialiste
travaille beaucoup en ce moment à
l'assemblée est cette semaine va
commencer exceptionnellement au mardi
avec nicolas sarkozy qui s'en prend à la
fraude sociale pas assez d'argent dans
les caisses alors en ce mardi nicolas
sarkozy décide d'aller en chercher un
peu dans la poche des fraudeurs en
déplacement à bordeaux le chef de l'état
fait de la fraude sociale son cheval de
bataille au passage et la non venue de
nouveaux pour les bénéficiaires du rsa
explications de marion lachguer la
fraude sociale elle s'annonce comme l'un
des thèmes de campagne
un sujet très populaire auprès des
électeurs de droite qui nicolas sarkozy
s'en est saisie passage à l'offensive
d'un président qui se pose en garant et
protecteur du modèle social français
celui qui perçoit des allocations
familiales alors qu'il ne réside pas sur
le territoire national comme celui qui
invente un logements fictifs
ou louent un logement insalubre pour
détourner des prestations vol les
français je vous le dis nous devons être
sans indulgence contre les fraudeurs et
contre les tricheurs les droits et les
devoirs c'est le slogan de la droite
et d'ici la fin de l'année dans une
dizaine de départements les
bénéficiaires du rsa vont devoir
travailler sept heures par semaine
nicolas sarkozy l'a confirmé un haut
conseil du financement de la protection
sociale sera chargé d'élaborer des
propositions pour combattre sans
indulgence la fraude sociale
l'un des secteurs visés par la droite
c'est celui de la santé à l'assemblée
xavier bertrand la firme la lutte contre
les fraudes à l'assurance maladie est
une priorité
la justice sociale c'est bien évidemment
de faire attention à ce que personne ne
vole la sécurité sociale
dans un rapport dominique tian estimait
la fraude sociale à 20 milliards d'euros
la cour des comptes elle évalue la
fraude aux prestations sociales à 4
milliards d'euros loin des 15 milliards
de fraudes aux cotisations sociales des
entreprises en arrivent à penser que
nicolas sarkozy est déjà en campagne
devinez je vous pose la question et non
je pense pas si j'ai un conseil à donner
à mes habits pour notre propre campagne
c'est de faire la vidéo tout simplement
monsieur monsieur sarkozy détient un
talent absolument admirable pour fer
l'opposant dans la séquence mais que
fait le gouvernement y compris quand il
y donc je pense que l'on année là je
pense que nous nous serions un peu
maladroit en dix ans la fraude sociale
n'est pas un problème sur ce point là
monsieur sarkozy quel que soit le
vocabulaire qui l'emploie dit quelque
chose de vrai bon après c'est compliqué
moi je respecte le travail de la cour
d'école parce qu'ils sont très
méthodique mépris à l'art du conte
robert sur les montants mais c'est déjà
moins
comment dire où est satisfaisant
intellectuellement si on voit que c'est
bien des arguments électoraux que ces
destinations médiatique etc
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
pourrions faire quelque chose d'assez
utile qu'ils demanderaient pas beaucoup
de travail qui est de reprendre des
séquences de discours de monsieur
sarkozy candidat
elle a été longtemps candidat si on vous
souvenez 1 et des séquences de ce qui me
dit maintenant et je pense se serait
divertissant de voir que il dit
exactement la même chose en espérant de
nouveau à terme si rien n'avait changé
espérons de nouveau attiré la sympathie
l'intérêt des français en jouant sur
simplement la perte de mémoire
donc c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'avoir envie de mémoriser tout ce que
monsieur sarkozy a dit dans cv dans ses
discours en 2005 - 2006 pour avoir envie
d'occuper sa mémoire autre chose mais
est ce que je veux dire c'est que ce que
nous voyons sous nos yeux et je pourrai
enfin on pourrait trouver 10 exemple de
ça c'est bon sang mais c'est bien sûr il
faut qu'on se donne des priorités
étrange étrange il ya une mesure
concrète qui l'annonçaient faire
travailler les bénéficiaires du rsa
sceptre par semaine ce sera expérimenté
dans une dizaine de départements
est-ce que c'était une façon finalement
de réinsérer un petit peu c'est
d'ailleurs dans ma mémoire mais vous
allez me détromper il me semble bien que
l'objet essentiel de la transformation
du rmi rsa par la même majorité
je voulais un président de la république
c'était ça mais mais pour l'intéressé a
moyennement fonctionné pour ceux qui ne
sont que je n'ai pas dit ça permet aussi
de cumuler un emploi je ne vous le fais
pas dire aussi c'est un échec
pourquoi employer tout de suite des
modiques lui sont les constats françois
fillon la semaine dernière avait annoncé
un nouveau train de mesures pour
économiser 7 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires
le texte a été présenté ce mardi en
conseil des ministres avant d'être
défendu par les ministres concernés
ensuite devant la commission des
finances de l'assemblée
entre autres mesures
la retraite à 62 ans dès 2007 ou encore
la hausse du taux de tva de 5 à 7 et
demi pour cent à l'ats richard vous qui
avait été à une époque dans une autre
vie à l'assemblée rapporteur c'est un
deuxième plan de rigueur qui en appelle
un troisième jeune papa je préférerais
que ce soit nicole bricq prendre qu'à
moi parce qu'elle est allée dans le rôle
maintenant donc je n'aimerais pas tenir
de propos approximatifs sur ces sujets
qui sont sérieux ce que je souhaite
simplement dire c'est qu'en effet je
pense que le gouvernement a bien fait de
reconnaître que la prévision antérieure
de croissance n'était pas exacte parce
qu'on savait vérifier le stylo en main
qui effectivement quand vous avez loupé
votre prévision croissance notre
exécution budgétaire prend une drôle de
tête parce que il ya en particulier de
ressources très très très importante qui
réalise pratiquement la semaine près au
basculement conjoncturelles sont à tva
ça se voit quand même et les cotisations
sociales pareil donc vous pouvez pas
enfin si vous essayez de vivre avec une
prévision de base imposable qui vont se
retrouver dans vos recettes fiscales qui
est fictive inquiétait etc à l'écart de
la réalité vous avez une fin d'exécution
budgétaire qui est tragique 2012 voilà
est bon on est tous ont eu tous a
souhaité que ce soit bien 1%
alors après les ajustements
quand vous faites un budget vous
commencez mois de février il ya quand
même beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
choix à faire beaucoup d'évaluation des
conséquences de ces choix vous bouclé
fin juillet et donc quand vous êtes
amené à reprendre l'exercice ensuite
vous faites forcément du travail de
rabotage un peu sommaire alors je salue
d'ailleurs au passage toujours le
savoir-faire sémantique de ce
gouvernement de cette majorité dire que
je vous ai tous entendu toute la presse
employer le terme d'économie pour parler
d'augmentation d'impôts tout le monde a
repris le terme région à faire des
économies on augmente la tva ça demande
du talent quand même s'agit
d'augmentations de recettes
monsieur s'il ya aussi quelques dépenses
que ces comprimés mais regarder
l'intervention
or j'ai entendu enfin j'ai plus
peut-être été inattentif et j'ai entendu
dans 95% des cas tous les bulletins
d'information tous les plateaux et c'est
tout le monde reprenait c'est un tout
petit déficit de distance critique ceux
qui étaient dans les dossiers de presse
en disant c'est des économies il y avait
entre eux suivre les cas puisque deux
phases entre 50 et 80% du rattrapage des
déficits qui étaient de l'augmentation
des prélèvements
c'est pas un gros mot mais simplement
après nous avons ce problème du tabou
que ces données a lui-même monsieur
sarkozy parce que c'est ça c'est quelque
chose que son identité politique et
c'est pour moi un marqueur de
conservatisme tout à fait solide c'est
voler quand même faire un peu de
politique comparée
il a il a une répulsion mellor psychique
contre l'idée de fiscalité et c'est
curieux pour quelqu'un qui est de la
réforme si je sais que c'est pas un
petit peu partagé par tous par tous les
candidats à l'élection présidentielle de
façon générale
de ce point de vue là vous pouvez
constater avec je crois objectivité pour
ma part même avec un peu d'admiration
que françois hollande qui connaît fort
bien ces questions là parce que
président il était d'en bas mais je vais
en dire un mot maintenant il y avait
quelques années malheureusement quand
j'étais à porter et donc je vais tout
une équipe de bon connaisseur des
questions fiscales et financières à la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
qui travaillent avec moi
françois faisait partie que du bien ces
sujets là honnêtement on est obligé de
reconnaître que l ça depuis des mois les
mois enfin le clip il a commencé sa
campagne et a toujours été clair sur
cette question
nous aurons besoin d'eux prélèvements
supplémentaires
puis on entend profondément modifier le
volet recettes du projet de loi de
finances
c'est d'ailleurs l'occasion aussi pour
présenter ses propres choix fiscaux
mounir souci un passage à la moulinette
au sénat la majorité de gauche entend
bien démonté pièce par pièce les mesures
phares du quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
après la sécurité sociale le projet de
loi de finances du gouvernement
n'échappera pas à la règle
bilou tabou les amendements déposés par
la gauche ressemble fort au programme
fiscal que françois hollande pourrait
défendre dans les prochaines semaines
c'est clair l'avenir mais surtout
j'essaie aussi c'est le boulot du
rapporteur général il ya que lui ou elle
en l'occurrence qui peut le faire de
faire aussi une certaine pédagogie
bien sûr à l'égard du gouvernement qui
est à mon avis sa folle suppression de
la taxe soda l'instauration d'un
prélèvement sur la spéculation à court
terme avec des amendements de ce type la
majorité politise les débats pour faire
ressortir ses propositions un
comportement néfaste selon la droite
je pense qu'ils regardent trop dans le
rétroviseur c'est à dire qu'il s'efforce
de recycler les débats que nous avons
déjà eu
mais ce n'est pas comme ça que la
crédibilité de la démarche du candidat
hollande va se construire pour l'avenir
la gauche m du sénat fait de la haute
assemblée son laboratoire 2012 la
campagne présidentielle est déjà en
marche au palais du luxembourg dernière
est devenue le laboratoire de la gauche
oui j'apprécie moi l'expression la
gauche m du sénat j'ai quand même le
sentiment que depuis que cette majorité
est en place et se comporte de façon
démocratique pas passer ça et donner
lieu à contestation
en revanche c'est vrai donc je
n'emploierai pas enfin je rejoindrai pas
le terme qui était dans votre sujet de
démontage des projets
gouvernement ou de la droite c'est
simplement la présentation d'
alternatives comme je le disais tout à
l'heure ça me paraît être temps d'en
dire un espèce de smic et les salaires
evans et de la critique c'est à dire que
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure face
à un enjeu un sujet une préoccupation de
la société ou de l'état il ya souvent
plusieurs solutions ça vaut la peine de
les débattre
donc je je je je je mentirais si je
disais que nous nous sentons prêts
surtout jeu j'ai un peu appris au cours
de différents épisodes que la cohérence
la continuité et la crédibilité d'une
action politique ça demande pas mal de
travail donc il ya sans doute encore des
points à améliorer dans certaines des
propositions que nous présentons terme
de laboratoire est bon parce que nous
opposons de la droite du sénat
évidemment commencé à éplucher les
propositions que nous faisons montre
éventuellement les faiblesses c'est un
travail utile et d'ailleurs exercé dans
un esprit très démocratique mais je n'ai
rien à dire en termes de climat et de
qualité des rapports pense que notre
nouvelle minorité
parce que didier bertrand non moi je ne
parle pas mais j'essaie de me m'exprimer
avec correction donc ça fait une
différence avec ce monsieur
et moi je parle de nos opposants au sein
de la droite sénatoriale dont je salue
le fair play et la volonté de faire du
bon travail peut être différent aux
aidants dans le monde politique est
simplement nous ça nous oblige à
perfectionner à clarifier éventuellement
à recaler un certain nombre des
propositions sur lesquelles elles
étaient déjà en réflexion donc on est
dans une phase en effet de comment dire
d'achèvement de la cohérence de nos
propositions pour gouverner nationaux
c'est pour ça qu'ils n'ont pas suivi
les débats à l'assemblée sans sûrement
nombreux malheureusement on veut on peut
juste se rappeler qu on peut juste se
rappeler quand même que sans surprise
vous allez chercher l'argent du côté des
revenus du capital
venu du côté des des revenus des plus
aisés également vous remettez en cause
le paquet tepa avec notamment
l'exonération fait attention
c'est normal qu'un débat politique soit
polarisé que dans kenny jambe gauche qui
disent des choses à l'endroit de crise
au contraire si les sujets objectifs
connus dont je connais beaucoup de gens
de droite qui n'ont toujours pas compris
pourquoi il y avait ce qu'il ya dans le
pack était pas dire que économiquement
exonération supplémentaire et
économiquement
quel est le profit de cela et recoins de
l'économie c'est ça quand même un petit
contenu scientifique on peut vérifier
des rapports entre les causes et les
effets tous les gens qui connaissent ces
questions savait que la quasi totalité
de ce qui était dans le paquet tepa
n'avait aucun impact sur la croissance
or par ne pas me pardonnez moi de vous
dire que quand même la question centrale
et elle l'est tout autant pour nous que
pour les gens qui sont aujourd'hui au
pouvoir c'est la compétitivité de ce
pays et son potentiel de croissance qui
a baissé
nous sommes devant une période
inquiétante de ce point de vue là et je
dis souvent à mes amis
heureusement que nous sommes pas dans le
contexte de 97 où il y avait un
potentiel de croissance plus élevé et
nous pouvions mener une politique qui
encourage à la demande sans que ce soit
essentiellement une augmentation des
importations
aujourd'hui la trans'arts
substantiellement baissé en
compétitivité et son potentiel de
croissance abaissée
le principal enjeu c'est ça il est quand
même déplorable que le paquet ait pas
puisqu'on devait en parler un instant
injustement les est était absolument un
fusil dont il va tirer dans les coins
voulez-vous me dire ce que ça a apporté
la croissance de ce pays
2 x 2 générations et la sécurité sociale
car les sénateurs n'ont pas seulement
remanié le budget ils ont également
entièrement réécrit le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
xavier bertrand n'a pas apprécié en
l'écoutant on ne sort de l'ambiguïté
qu'à ces dépenses est fait pour la
majorité
des sénatoriales le résultat est clair
plus de dépenses plus de prélèvements
le candidat socialiste a du mal à sortir
de l'ambiguïté vous vous l'avez fait
pour lui parce que le débat devient pas
un peu trop politisée au sénat c'est ce
que disait qu'il ya monsieur bertrand
ce sont ceux son tempérament qui parlent
chacun s'y prend à sa façon mais il ya
un phénomène plus intéressant que j'ai
perçu à plusieurs reprises tant à les
débats du sénat
beaucoup de membres du gouvernement sous
l'oeil du chef de l'état comme vous le
savez en tas de se sont donné un mandat
de doha teur de l'opposition ils le font
avec plus ou moins d'habileté et dans
son panier pourvus mais pour nous c'est
une ambiance assez particulière
ils sont ils se comportent gta mais
j'espère gentiment franchement c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup c'est une
collègue du conseil a à faire une brève
interruption à valérie pécresse parce
que s'était laissé entraîner dans son
propos pendant le débat budgétaire a
expliqué que nos propositions n'étaient
pas les bonnes et puis dans le emporté
par son propos il était en train de se
comporter comme si nous avions déjà
gagné depuis sept ans on a bien compris
que c'est une période réjouissante pour
ménages à part c'est quand même pas bon
signe pour une majorité que une part
tient aussi important de sa thématique
consiste à dire vous savez les gens d'en
face sont vraiment pas bon et ils font
des propositions qui tiennent pas du
tout en l'air manière à finalement faire
passer sous la table leur propre bilan à
leurs propres propositions pour l'avenir
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
l'épisode pourtant significatif monsieur
le maire est un garçon
talentueux productifs qui sait
travailler il a produit
il avait tout un tas groupe de travail
tout à fait estimable de l'ump un projet
pour la période 2012 2017
j'ai compris que en gros à l'ump plus
personne ne voulait entendre parler de
ce projet en dissociant tour en parle
plus
c'était juste une contrainte c'est donc
je crois comprendre qu'il ya un petit
problème de leur côté voyou allez on va
passer au mercredi on va aussi un petit
preuve de votre côté également avec le
mariage des socialistes et des verts
quand l'union rire à la scène de ménage
ce devait être un accord a minima mais
harmonieux mardi soir les socialistes et
les verts se sont entendus sur un
programme en vue de 2012 accord
notamment sur le nucléaire ou sur le
nombre de circonscriptions qu'ils
reviendront aux écologistes mais on ce
mercredi l'union tourner au vinaigre
les verts s'aperçoivent que les
socialistes ont enlevé un paragraphe
dans le texte final
explications de jérémy hartmann hier
soir le bureau national du ps devait
marquer la fin du long feuilleton des
négociations entre socialistes et
écologistes
un peu plus tôt dans la journée martine
aubry et cécile duflot s'étaient
rencontrés pour signer l'accord tant
attendu mais c'était sans compter sur
l'intervention inopinée du groupe areva
inquiets pour l'avenir économique de son
activité le géant du nucléaire français
contacter le parti socialiste pour lui
demander le retrait d'un paragraphe du
texte portant sur l'arrêt du
retraitement et de la filière du mox un
combustible fabriqué à partir de
plutonium et d'uranium appauvri
depuis les socialistes ont fait machine
arrière et reparle de l'utilité du mox
il nous faut bien évidemment
gardez la filière knox vous permet de
vous rappeler que si on est favorable à
le p r de flamanville et c'est la
position de françois hollande
celui ci fonctionne au mox
incompréhension chez les écologistes
pour eux il ne peut pas y avoir de
retour en arrière
le texte signé par martine aubry est le
seul valable quand vous avez un texte
est signé par exemple entre deux chefs
d'état c'est celui qui vaut la même
façon le texte a été acté entre martine
aubry et cécile duflot c'est celui là
qui vont les écologistes surtout
inquiets de voir areva essayer
d'influencer leurs alliés socialistes
je crois que ça en dit long sur la
conception que le lobby nucléaire de la
démocratie tir de penser que l'industrie
nucléaire pourrait influencer une
discussion entre deux formations
politiques de l'opposition qui essaye de
réfléchir à qu'est ce que serait une
stratégie énergétique de demain
je trouve ça extrêmement préoccupant ce
week-end europe ecologie les verts doit
faire valider l'accord conclu avec les
socialistes à ces instances fédérales
ils se baseront sur la version signée
par martine aubry est tant pis si les
socialistes ont depuis changé d'avis
alors finalement suite du feuilleton les
deux parties ont signé un texte commun
jeudi parlant d'une réduction de
l'utilisation du combustible mox ce que
vous convenez quand même que tout ça
donne une image bien brouillonne des
intentions françois hollande sur le
nucléaire
si je disais le contraire honnêtement je
reviens ruinerait la crédibilité tout ce
que je raconte dont le reste du
mission donc bien entendu c'est une
erreur peut-être campagne ratée de
conception c'est à dire que quand vous
essayez de faire ce que nous avons fait
l'effort de faire un programme de
gouvernement une liste nature assez
complet ça doit mobiliser
vous entendrez souvent parlé de
cohérence ça doit mobiliser beaucoup de
gens qui ont des connaissances des
savoir-faire de
les compétences politiques aux pratiques
dans une quantité de domaines très
variés et en même temps les équipes de
négociateurs sont pas très nombreuses ne
pouvait pas faire venir tous vos
spécialistes de tous donc il ya et c'est
vrai dans une dénonciation de partie
c'est vrai aussi dans une négociation de
gouvernement à gouvernement
et ça m'a bien le faire une remarque est
que nous avons un système majoritaire
c'est très important parce que ces
accords je voudrais je voudrais finir
dans un système majoritaire vous faites
les accords avant les élections les
électeurs les voix dans pratiquement
tout le reste de l'europe avant leur
attentive à sa qui fonctionne avec la
proportionnelle est parti se
concurrencent ceux s'opposent souvent
assez vertement et sont obligés une fois
élu de faire des accords de coalition
qu'il négocie pendant trois quatre ou
cinq semaines dans lequel tout doit être
prévu nous nous faisons avant et sous
les yeux des électeurs avant qu'il vote
n'a qu il vaut mieux après non c'est pas
mon avis parce que précisément leurs
proches centrale que je fais la
proportionnelle c'est qu'elle ne donne
jamais aux chers électeurs eux-mêmes le
droit de choisir une majorité et une
coalition notre système et lobbies
chacun et donc c'est très dommageable
pour les partis qui sont incapables
d'entrer dans une coalition
ils sont isolés ils l'ont choisi
politiquement lequel je me donne c'est
le cas du front national dans un
registre très différent ce système
il permet à l'électeur devenir cette
alliance là qui va être en mesure de
gouverner pendant cinq ans je lui donne
mon vote et je sais où je vais alors que
si vous mettez en belgique
suivent était en allemagne fédérale
s'ils votent et même en italie où
étaient pas des partis et ensuite ils
seront propriétaires de la majorité
qu'ils formeront que vous ayez été
d'accord ou pas non j'en reviens à mon
affaire de négociation bon c'est clair
que c'est un gros loupé de négociations
je tire mon chapeau à ceux qui l'ont
réglé après parce que je pense que ce
qui est maintenant écrit dans le texte
est cohérent et correspond à la réalité
c'est à dire que
il n'y a pas de sortie du nucléaire et
un recadrage de la part du nucléaire
dans la production énergétique et donc
naturellement la production de
combustibles qui est en même temps c'est
pour ça que c'est un sujet très vifs
avec les avec europe ecologie les verts
le mox est en même temps un moyen de
traiter en profondeur le problème des
déchets parce que c'est un recyclage de
matières fissiles
merci je jugeais les réactions des mini
jeux fait à leur place
inepte qui probablement est une bonne
nouvelle pour les verts et pour cécile
duflot qui si j'ai bien compris a gagné
une circonscription à paris
mais pour pour la france de ce vin
dépendance pour le pouvoir d'achat des
français et pour l'industrie française
se serait littéralement une pure
catastrophe est une ineptie
il peut y avoir un débat politique d'un
côté et électorale d'un côté il peut y
avoir un débat sur le nucléaire de
l'autre encore une fois l'opinion à
libre moi je respecte les opinions sur
le sujet mais à les échanger les
circonscriptions contre des réacteurs
nucléaires c'est justement cela vient
c'est du pain béni pour la majorité
c'est bien qu'ils en profitent c'est
rare qu'ils aient finalement une
capacité offensive dans le débat
politique à l'heure actuelle donc moi je
leur souhaite d'en profiter pendant 24
ou 48 heures et après on va revenir au
travail normal mais mauvaise fille je
termine sur mon affaire de cohérence
qu'honnêtement du fait de son parcours
et de l'ombrière tout un débat sur son
expérience moi j'ai une petite idée sur
la question
françois hollande est quelqu'un sur qui
j'ai aucun doute en termes de volonté de
cohérence il sait ce que c'est que le
piloter une équipe diverse avec des
problèmes très varié et très compliqué
est de savoir que si vous commencez à
aller dans des approches contradictoires
ou pas harmonisés et forcément tout
mélanger en un clic qui n'était pas quoi
faire là vous ne pouvez pas tout piloter
en temps réel
ça n'arrive jamais le risque zéro
n'existe pas on est un cas je trouve
une autre différence avec nos amis
europe ecologie les verts
il ne croit pas au système présidentiel
n'en sert votre question en son temps il
déteste ce système et ils ont énormément
ils n'ont pas la volonté de se situer
dedans sauf qu'il existe
moi j'ai une version beaucoup plus là
titre personnel beaucoup plus nuancée
parce qu'au moins ils organisent la
cohérence et puis il crée de
responsabilité faciale vis-à-vis de
l'opinion démocratique dans ces
conditions dans notre campagne à nous il
ya un patron
quel candidat qui assume la
responsabilité et qui assume les risques
d'où vient le voit donc nous avons un
problème d'articulation entre le parti
et le candidat pour les verts c'était
visible c'était un accord de parti à
parti classique comme si on était dans
un régime parlementaire petites erreurs
nous sommes dans un régime où la clé de
voûte c'est l'élection présidentielle
est une élection uninominale donc à la
fin il faut que nous et j'ai pleinement
confiance entre martine aubry et
françois hollande pour que ça marche
parce que c'est dans leur culture et qui
sait des gens qui sont l'un et l'autre
des gens de choix et de rigueur mais
nous avons ce défi on a payé cash
parce que c'est une boulette face et
honnêtement je pense que nos
négociateurs il y avait 50 au dossier en
juin on pas vu que le dossier du mox la
proposition qui leur étaient faites et
est sympathique mais qu' elle consistait
que les verts ont toujours beaucoup joué
sur la question des déchets pour essayer
de faire disparaître la filière
nucléaire qui est ce que le rpt pense à
beaucoup de temps là juste en une
question rapide est ce que les
écologistes ont toujours été un allié
difficile et ça se confiant tout allié
est difficile sinon ce serait aux
favelas tout particulièrement nous non
vous êtes trop jeune pour avoir connu ça
mais j'avais toujours ça
et avec le pc nous avons vécu des
moments aussi assez tonique n'est ce pas
et après c'est pour ça que moi j'obtiens
autant origines majoritaire tous les
sous l'oeil du public
voyez monsieur mélenchon le chouchou de
la presse de droite ce n'est pas facile
non plus qui fait ce qu'il faut pour
vous la dé ce statut le pc d'aujourd'hui
se dit est ce bien la façon intelligente
de mener la campagne parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont sous l'oeil de tout
l'électorat de gauche alors à la richard
va continuer donc avec l'équipe de
françois hollande justement pierre
moscovici directeur de campagne a
présenté l'équipe qui va accompagner le
candidat dans sa campagne beaucoup de
monde dans cette équipe où sont
représentés tous les courants c'est un
sujet de bérangère d'un glace comme
prévu c'est pierre moscovici qui sera le
grand ordonnateur autour de lui une
équipe si nombreuse qu'elle a du mal à
prendre place sur la scène de la maison
de l'amérique latine et personne n'a été
oublié
les fidèles de françois hollande comme
stéphane le foll mais aussi les anciens
adversaires des primaires il n'y aura
pas de cacophonie
au contraire nous avons veillé à ce que
tout le monde soit présent parce que
tout soit articulé et cette fois ci les
socialistes seront tous unis avec leurs
amis radicaux au tour leur candidat pour
pas question de renouveler les erreurs
de la campagne de 2007 qui avait vu
ségolène royal se passer du plein
soutien de la direction du parti la
première secrétaire martine aubry est
nommé conseiller politique elle se rend
liaison permanente avec françois
hollande
moi je suis là pour veiller à ce que
le parti se mettre totalement au service
du pont du las le mot d'ordre se veut
être le rassemblement entendu dans
toutes les bouches si l'équipe de
campagne fait la part belle à tous les
courants du parti et même aux radicaux
ni ségolène royal ni arnaud montebourg
ne feront partie de l'organigramme
manuel valls est lui récompensé de son
soutien rapide au candidat hollande
il prend les rênes du pôle communication
autour de lui deux proches de ségolène
royal delphine batho et najat belkacem
qu'elle présente
ce qui les régissent hollande et puis
vraiment
et si grave parce que j'ai confiance le
candidat son tour d'un cabinet
thématique 22 personnalités chargées
d'intervenir sur des thèmes précis
parmi eux vincent peillon à l'éducation
françois rebsamen
le président du groupe ps au sénat sera
lui chargé de la sécurité
voir l'analyse qui est arrivé derrière
c'était armée mexicaine
ça va peut-être pas aidé pour la
coordination dont vous parlais tout à
l'heure c'est une image d'un jour
ensuite ce qui compte c'est simplement
le travail que tous produits l'image
d'un jour mais toujours beaucoup de
conseillers beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnes autour de françois hollande
gagne satisfaire tous les courants on a
l'impression
il aurait bien mon avis il a mieux fait
de faire comme ça parce que sinon c'est
normal que vous les titres conduire vous
êtes obligés de faire des titres sur ces
choses là comme dirait un de mes vieux
amis il n'y a rien de plus perry mais
qu'un journal de la veille hrc c'est un
événement qui a disparu déjà françois a
fait son équipe de façon évidemment
rationnelle en tenant compte de tout un
tas de choses là aussi des aspirations
personnelles dans tout ça avez vous
remarqué l'arrivée sur la photo c'est
assez humain et donc c'est une bonne
conciliation des impératifs
contradictoires maintenant ce qui compte
c'est comment ça fonctionne alors on va
passer au jeudi et l'ambiance est
toujours aussi tendue au sénat
c'est à l'issue d'un débat animé et qui
s'est achevée au petit matin que le
sénat a voté pour la suppression du
conseiller territorial
ce nouvel ennemi et l'ufp qui doit
siéger à la fois au département et à la
région
la gauche évoque un sursaut démocratique
pour justifier son refus de la mesure
phare de la réforme des collectivités
qui doit entrer en vigueur en 2014
aurélia romano jusqu'au bout de la nuit
c'est à 5 heures du matin qui est tombé
le conseiller territorial
après une âpre bataille d'hémicycle une
bataille de tranchées fait de rappel au
règlement d'interpellation et de vote
sur les procédures
vous avez voulu faire voter le sénat moi
personnellement je pense qu'on aurait dû
demander au bureau de se réunir vous
n'avez pas voulu le faire c'était votre
droit monsieur le président mais dans ce
cas précis on devait voter à main levée
et moi je considère que véritablement
sur ce point il y à quelque chose qui
est entaché d'illégalité
jean léonce dupont présidente centriste
de la séance a eu du mal à appeler au
calme
à de nombreuses reprises s'il vous plaît
mes chers collègues et essayons essayons
de rester les uns et les autres
extrêmement sauvage une séance qui
s'inscrit dans un climat tendu au sénat
on se fait insulter
et le pire c'est que nous étions plus
nombreux que la gauche cette séance sans
fin a eu raison du ministre présent
philippe richert tout à la cause de la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
voulue par nicolas sarkozy ministre à
l'emploi du temps bouleversé demain
matin fa c'est à dire tout à l'heure je
devais ouvrir je devais ouvrir le
congrès de la r f je serai donc dans
l'obligation de ne pas aller à l'air f
je le regrette beaucoup le sénat le
sénat est prioritaire le pape non c'est
moi qui ouvre c'est moi qui ouvrait dans
quelques heures
l'abrogation du conseiller territorial a
finalement été adoptée à 181 voix contre
137 pour autant le texte a peu de
chances d'être discuté à l'assemblée
nationale l'assemblée peut prendre notre
texte ou ne pas le prendre le voter ou
ne pas le voter
le gouvernement peut l'inscrire ou ne
pas l'inscrire c'est leur problème
pour nous il est important que nous
soyons en accord avec nos convictions
avec ce que nous pensons les socialistes
affirment prendre de l'avancé sur un
éventuel basculement de l'assemblée en
alors hier le conseiller territorial
c'est ce qui a fait perdre le sénat à la
droite
non la réforme territoriale était quand
même des crues et les grands pas
principalement ce point là parce que ça
concerne le personnel politique des
conseils généraux et des conseils
régionaux qui est comme vous le savez
est marginale dans le collège
sénatoriales donc ça c'est secondaire
oui vous a pas échappé dans le vote que
les centristes partage pas l'adhésion
conseiller territorial
ils se sont abstenus vous voyez les
chiffres se sont abstenus sur la
disposition qu'ils le suppriment les
eaux salées moi vous vous rappelez bien
que si la très critique quant à elle été
adoptée avec une majorité extrêmement
réduite et qui avait demandé beaucoup de
travail à l'ump à ce moment là parce que
les centristes net est fondamentalement
pas d'accord la réforme territoriale ya
des tas de sujets dont on peut parler le
conseiller territorial
on sait que c'était une magouille
électorale c'était un moyen d'essayer de
rattraper le contrôle d'un certain de
conseillers régionaux
après les avoir perdus de rendre dans
les urnes et la preuve d'ailleurs que
cette majorité afin que ce mouvement
l'ump ce gouvernement n'y croyez pas que
une fois que le conseiller territorial
été votée il fallait donc créer les 3900
nouveaux cantons pour qu'ils puissent
être élus en temps et en heure et nous
rien de plus pressé de dire on va pas le
faire donc
à supposer que ce texte subsiste ce qui
m'étonnerait quelle que soit l'hypothèse
en 2012 je pense n'a pas une chance de
s'appliquer six axes supposer que la
réforme territoriale dans son ensemble
si monsieur sarkozy est réélu en 2012 et
là l'on donnera la création du
conseiller territorial pense qu'ils ont
fait bien plus grand mal à le faire la
preuve c'est qu'ils n'ont pas commencé à
le faire et avec un sénat cette annonce
avait non seulement ça non parce que
maintenant c'est le décret mais refaire
tout perte ou le commander re toute la
carte politique française en regroupant
toute la france en nouveau canton
c'est un domaine dans lequel j'ai un peu
l'expérience cite une source de conflit
absolument
un maîtrisable ils ne le seront pas
reconnaissons quand même qu'il faut
alléger ce fameux millefeuille
territorial le sucre au système nous
avons nous une autre réponse qui est
d'avoir ce que nous appelons des
conférences des compétences c'est-à-dire
un échange de vues et éventuellement des
décisions de nouveau partage des
compétences entre départements et
régions
en revanche moi j'ai de sérieux doutes
sur l'enjeu financier de la suppression
d'un des deux niveaux et est d'ailleurs
ceci n'est pas en débat donc l'argument
du gouvernement faire des économies ce
n'est pas un bon argument ce jeu vous
comprenez bien que quand vous êtes un
département qui dépensent 1 milliard et
demi ou deux milliards d'euros par an
pour 50 % en actions sociales qui ont
les bénéficiaires des prestataires ou en
entretien de routes ou en gestion de
grands espaces naturels etc
le coût de l'assemblée élue sur votre
milliards de budget et représente trop 4
millions donc c'est une plaisanterie
c'est un défi à l'intelligence de
raconter que d'avoir deux assemblées à
une assemblée élue au lieu de deux a un
impact et économique quelconque
le vrai sujet qui est calée sur lesquels
moi je me garde de prendre des positions
péremptoire
c'est la difficulté sur des projets
d'investissement tgv type grands
ouvrages ont matière d'environnement et
cetera
c'est de combiner les objectifs d'un
département et d'une région qui se
traduisent par des règles de financement
par les choix de financement ils peuvent
être difficiles à concilier ça c'est un
vrai sujet et je pense que nous avons
les progrès à faire de ce côté là en
revanche l'idée de dire comme ça d'une
pichenette on va supprimer une des deux
assemblée afin d'aider une des deux
institutions personne ne la défend
personne de la défense est d'avoir une
seule assemblée pour les deux est une
fausse bonne idée et elle a été inspirée
on va terminer avec du cinéma et la
sortie cette semaine du film l'ordre et
la morale qui relate l'histoire de la
prise d'otages et de l'assaut de la
grotte d'ouvéa en nouvelle-calédonie
c'était en 88 à deux jours de l'élection
de présidentielle françois mitterrand
était président jacques chirac premier
ministre l'assaut a fait 21 morts
simon barbarie 23 ans après l'assaut de
la grotte d'ouvéa le regard
cinématographique de mathieu kassovitz
soulève de nouvelles polémiques
l'action du film l'ordre et la morale se
situe au mois de mai 1988 entre les deux
tours de l'élection présidentielle en
nouvelle calédonie une gendarmerie est
attaqué par des indépendantistes kanaks
trois gendarmes sont tués et une
trentaine sont pris en otage est détenu
dans la grotte d'ouvéa des négociations
s'engagent mais une semaine plus tard
l'assaut est lancé par les militaires le
bilan est lourd de militaires sont tués
et 19 indépendantistes dont certains
avant la libération des otages c est
très nette hors piste ou en situation
d'exception que la cohabitation entre un
gouvernement de droite et représente
gauche qu'il est hostile
comme il a tranché en dehors des
procédures habituelles
et puis une semaine que la prise d'otage
a commencé au second tour des élections
dans quelques jours seulement un signe
ne trompe pas une solution pacifique
dans les heures qui viennent
très pur maîtrise de la situation
cette version est formellement réfutée
par le ministre de l'outre-mer de
l'époque bernard pons
il fait part de son indignation et
pointe le manque d'objectivité du film
le général vidal en charge de l'assaut
au moment des faits enfonce le clou et
déclare que même françois mitterrand
avait la conviction d'un échec des
négociations le film ne laisse en tout
cas pas la classe politique indifférente
le parti socialiste était venu en nombre
la semaine dernière à l'avant première
alors vous nous avez dit que vous n'avez
pas encore vu donc peut pas savoir si
ses proches ou pas de la réalité
c'était dix ans je suppose j'ai un tout
petit peu de huy expérience dans
l'exercice des fonctions d'état
dans un cas comme ça il ya sur le pain
beaucoup de gens qui connaissent tout la
réalité de ce qui s'est passé au moment
de l'assaut avait quand même des
personnels opérationnels des chefs
d'opération qui sont un peu pâle et cela
ça bosse l'intégralité de ce qui s'est
passé à l'ats richard c'est la plainte
at elle ainsi à vous merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous et nous nous
retrouvons quant à nous la semaine
prochaine même lieu même heure
oh